fans are gearing up for the game parking
seems to be on everyone's mind once
again at allegiant stadium madison
kimbrough is live with what officials
are saying is your best bet when
attending tomorrow's game madison
yeah you know ever since alleged stadium
opened here in las vegas parking has
been an issue but things have been on
the up and up with recent events and
preseason games as you can see we're
here at allegiant stadium
many fans have decided to go with season
parking a pricey but sure way of finding
a spot on game day several lots on and
off allegiance property are available as
well if you aren't one of those who have
season parking getting dropped off is
probably your best bet this way you can
avoid the cost of parking and the walk
making for an easier time arriving at
the gates for entry county commissioner
michael naft says the rtc game day
express has proven to be a great option
for fans four dollars round trip or two
dollars each way you can get to the
stadium from a variety of different
places
it's i think it's the best bang for your
buck but you get a to pull up pretty
close to the stadium walk out and get in
in quick fashion a reminder if you are
driving to the stadium the hacienda
bridge will close at noon on monday for
pedestrians
again your best option to finding a
space if you do decide to drive on your
own is to leave early suggested about
two and a half hours ahead of game time
is suggested as that would probably give
you enough time to find a space and be
able to get into the entryway as easy as
possible reporting live madison kimbro 8
news now